you know a movie is going to be a
heart-wrenching experience when even the
trailer has people in tears fans just
couldn't contain their emotions when the
new trailer for Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 hit during the Super Bowl Marvel
Studios used the Super Bowl to unveil a
brand new trailer for volume 3. the
final entry in director James Gunn's
Guardians Trilogy and his last project
with Marvel before moving on to head up
the DC Universe full-time are you ready
for
Last Ride the director was already on
double duty on Super Bowl Sunday
promoting the new Flash trailer on his
Twitter just moments before his Guardian
spot Guardians volume 3 reunites The
Ensemble of Chris Pratt Zoe Saldana Dave
Batista Bradley Cooper pomp clementia
Vin Diesel and Karen Gillen and
introduces Cosmo played by Maria
bakalova Adam Warlock played by Will
Poulter and the villainous High
evolutionary played by chikuri awuji
releasing just a couple of months after
February's Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 looks set to continue MCU Phase 5 with
higher Stakes heart and sacrifice than
we've seen before the imminent danger of
this band of Misfits final Adventure is
obvious in the marketing with released
footage causing many fans online to
panic about the fates of the characters
they've grown to love as one fan wrote
on Twitter this is going to break our
hearts isn't it indeed if there's one
thing fans can expect from a James Gunn
Marvel film aside from offbeat humor and
perfect needle drops it's a heavy dose
of heartbreak the first Guardians of the
Galaxy film saw the original Groot
sacrifice himself for his Newfound
family in the second Peter's adopted
father yondu played by Michael Rooker
gave up his life for his boy he may have
been your father boy but he wasn't your
daddy
given that this is the last film in
Gunn's nearly 10-year Guardian Saga it's
likely he won't leave any heartstring
untucked in other words as one fan
tweeted we aren't ready for the pain
gyms some fans couldn't even survive
this small snippet of footage without
getting misty-eyed one tweeted this
trailer literally made me cry don't do
this to me another shared a photo of
John Cena's Peacemaker bawling his eyes
out with the caption James I can't do
this today I'm gonna cry yet another fan
claimed the trailer made them an
emotional wreck that will be
inconsolable until at least the film's
May 5th release date While most fans are
getting overwhelmed by the mere notion
of the Guardian series coming to an end
most are beside themselves with
preemptive grief over the death of a fan
favorite character judging by these
users one Guardian in particular seems
to be on the chomping block and no one
is ready to say goodbye in James Gunn's
Twitter mentions fans seemed to agree
that Rocket Raccoon will meet his maker
literally and figuratively in Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 and it's true that
the footage released in the first two
trailers doesn't exactly paint his
future in an optimistic light with the
character bathed in Heavenly white light
as he delivers this ominous slime we'll
all fly away together
one fan tweeted this trailer has the
stench of death Rockets gonna die isn't
he several other users expressed their
anxieties about Rocket's fate including
one who begged please let Rocket Raccoon
live another fan shared a foreboding
screenshot from the trailer of Peter
screaming in anguish over something
unseen noting that it likely signaled a
moment of unmatched pain yet to come
though the series seems determined to go
out on a bleak yet triumphant note fans
are nonetheless excited to experience
this pain together one tweeted this is
gonna be such an emotional movie knowing
it's the last Guardians film another
admitted I am simultaneously excited and
terrified of getting my heart torn into
shreds now you're just making it sad
perhaps the most succinct summation of
the mix of feelings going into the film
came in the form of this tweet I can
already tell this one is going to be
hitting me right in the fields and I
look forward to it
foreign
[Music]